ilan people want to know what books do
you recommend I like biographies in
general biographies I think are really
you know really interesting reader done
for them well I think you learn a lot
depending upon you know whose life
you're reading about there are lots of
lessons in there I read Isaacson's
biography of jobs which I thought was
quite interesting and I actually really
liked I am his vibrafree of mentioned
Franklin who I would say certainly one
of my heroes he seemed like a really
great guy
basically I sort of was thinking about
this one as when as a kid and trying to
find some meaning in life
like what's the meaning of life you know
and I quite sort of sad about it
actually when I was a teenager and then
I read The Hitchhiker's Guide to the
galaxy mm-hmm which basically said like
the thrill the rope you know the
basically universe is the answer and you
just need to figure out the questions so
I think you know that that's if I if I
can help kind of figure out the
questions then that I consider that to
be meaningful thank you guys so much for
watching I hope you enjoyed this series
I'd love to know have any of you read
the books and elong recommends did you
like them did you not leave it in the
comments below if you want me to
continue this series about famous
entrepreneurs and their books they're
reading
leave that in the comments below to
thank you again for watching continue to
believe and I'll see you soon